our country itself is sick
but it's lost its sense of direction
even its common decency you don't so
much as wiggler fingers
[Applause]
there's a lot of people saying a lot of
things
but in the end you gotta listen to
yourself
in that moment
elvis the man was sacrificed
and elvis the god was born
[Applause]
you're looking for trouble
you came to the right place
looking for trouble
just look right in my face
he had no idea what he had done
nothing
[Applause]
i wish to promote you mr presley
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
we don't do the business the business
will do you i'm going to do what i want
to do sing the music that i want
i get it
[Music]
not going to put me in jail
the way you sing is god-given
so there can't be nothing wrong with it
if you don't listen to me
now that your mama i sacrificed for you
would be for nothing
trust me
got a lot of talk about the new elvis
[Applause]
those people ain't gonna change me now
[Applause]
i think if you dream he'll do it
i've never met anyone like you
i hope not
we can't
[Music]
without me there would be no elvis
presley
whoever once told me
the things are too dangerous to say
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen here's elvis
presley
this ain't no nostalgia show
we're gonna do something different
[Music]
you